yeah I smack her butt all the way up the
stairs this is how you know you've been
together for a long time when their butt
defense is like [__] it man like they
butt defense yeah we go up and she knows
my combo so she's like
like left right left right block block
ham Street and I'm like what how how did
you know I was going to that's a spear
Wu
[Music]
thing
welcome back to careful boys where we
are talking about what are we talking
about we're talking about how to keep
the spark alive during a longterm
relationship who's been in the longest
in this year um Nick Nick I don't know
how many years Nick really um we've been
married for three years including the
puppy love been dating since like the
third grade yeah we've been dating since
you've been dating since 14 14 years
you've been dating her since she CHS
with someone else no
yeah yeah I'm a side piece I'm still a
side piece dog wait 14 years yeah I
think so yeah how long you 2008
was we're 2010 we're 2010 how many years
is that 16 this year so take it away bar
how do you keep the sparkle out 16 in
September or do you flicker the light
you flicker the
switch flicker keeping the spark Alive
by like sometimes he's making a stroll
party yeah it blows out you got to light
it up back up
what does that mean is that code for
something I don't know no I'm saying is
you're doing barely just enough to keep
the lights on no does the spark
sometimes blow out you got to re we got
to reignite he's got his Pilot how do
you keep it going I would say I mean we
definitely had our ups and downs but as
of recent probably like the last seven
or eight years been really really
good um I think honestly like talking to
each other but having a open heart and
open
communication is really really good
I've been doing that a little bit more
we've been like ribbing each other a
little bit more and talking a little
more [__] and and not be a night not as
nice as we used to be I feel like you
know being like hey you didn't do this
and then we have a conversation and like
either make a fun joke about it and then
leave it at that and then it's all good
no other [__] in a way where it means
something like there's no weight behind
it you're just talking [__] cuz I feel
like the most important thing is you got
to like be best friends first M and then
when you're best friends and you're like
really look forward to living life and
enjoying experiences together that's
number one like cuz once you start
building Separate Lives is really hard
to bring it back together that makes
sense I remember we were having a
Christmas party and [__] Steve and
Nikki were just talking so much [__] and
they're like we're going to [__] later
oh yeah and it was so funny I was like
oh yeah you guys whole [__] talk so much
[__] yeah yeah dude Steve's got excited
right now dude I I love that [__] man I
love that [__]
[__] [__] yeah no nobody can ever
push my buttons like she can it's insane
how well she can push my buttons like
it's actually like stunning that woman
can read me like a book and it's like oh
my God good for her cuz like I never
thought anyone ever could and then yeah
so she hits my buttons and then like I
pay it off inside of her
[__] well with both legs on her head Fu
it I got my [__] you know Timberlands
on
the only time you wear them yeah yeah
yeah soon CU I don't want to wreck the
carpet
upstairs he doesn't wear them outside
they're fresh box bro never I would
never noes carpet only carpet only the
double foot on the head I was trying to
picture there's a picture of it it's
actually pretty feminine looking yeah
you seen it no I don't know there's a
picture there's a picture of it yeah
it's feminine looking for the girl yeah
yeah for sure Kamasutra February Edition
yeah it's not feminine looking on me
I'll tell you that not of Steve but oh
just someone doing it let me make let me
let me masculine this for you imagine
but this is Nikki's head right here yeah
but but then Steve you're you're doing
yeah look there's a bunch of
different but it has to be both wait
wait go back most of these are two guys
so it's a little weird oh my God wait go
back go back go back of course they're
on Ryan's
phone yeah yeah yeah yeah that's the one
that's the one this gy this oh my god
look that's it no but it has to be both
you I'm thinking both got to be both
both it's funnier I feel like I've seen
that both Fe you is a hard P that's my
move you just got to be flexible good
hip flexers you know and thrusting at
the same time I do think on the on the
flip side the thing about all [__]
access
247 changes how thirsty I am are you
less thirsty yeah I forget about sex but
when I'm single all I think about is sex
all the time and I'm like I can't even
get work done because I'm either
masturbating or trying to go on a date
and then I'm like I wish one or the
other that level of thirst when I first
you know when you're like the first year
just [__] everywhere [__] all the
time and you just you don't [__] you
just get like door Dash and you keep
[__] you know and I'm like those days
door are over I miss those days just
leave it on the floor B H you're just
sweating all the time cuz I feel like
everything is now like sped up in a way
where like you're you do more quickies
or you try to fit it in here and then
you're just there's no like let's just
[__] get a cabin and [__] you
know and I'm like you have to really
like plan for that but then the the the
difference is you already with that
person so then how do you have that um
that feeling of like oh we're gonna
rendevu cuz you know we haven't seen
each other and that was my favorite
thing about long distance is like I get
to really miss her and then now we're
going to [__] our [__] brains out you
know yeah just your options and
availability changes the nature I
remember being younger and uh this is so
silly um but like you know when you know
uh when you knew you were going to bring
somebody over and it's like oh man I'm
not going to get ready for SX I'm going
to clean the room like I'm going to get
ready yeah you do things that are just
hilarious that you wouldn't give a [__]
about now as an older piece of [__]
right but like I would do things like
yeah for sure I would like clean the
[__] out of the spot I would do like 100
push-ups before she showed up [__]
your arms are super shaky and tired when
you're [__] yeah yeah I like that too
your triceps are cramping one of the
things I would do this is really funny
and but it just worked for me I'm just
saying it worked for me I would take
like two shots of whiskey but then brush
my teeth anyway just you don't have
whiskey dick solid no because the thing
is too much yeah when you don't drink
too much not too much for me if I took
two shots of whiskey I would be able to
actually last like two times longer your
liquid courage relax but not limp dick I
see so it was just a whole thing now
it's like I don't know maybe you get
desensitized and it's like the same
vagina that you had for a long time or
like you know you just I don't same old
same old you know what I
mean I'm like give me my 2 minutes and
I'm good unless you need it unless you
need it it is different when you coexist
with your part I kind of feel like the
novelty wears off because there's no
risk of rejection like it's not like in
the early where you're like oh I'm being
accepted I know consensuality is wow i'
be getting shot down all the time no but
like if you if you if you could just
wake up flip over stick it in and bust
yeah I mean that's a little bit
different from like all right man I go
[__] fly halfway across the world
let's get ready you know the [__]
just give it up eventually they too easy
okay that's the problem is you're too
easy know it used to be a game it's a
challenge my tip always goes you don't
take me on dates anymore I'm like what
are you talking about we just went on a
date we went to collector
go yeah I was like took you to dinner
she we watch the Adam Sandy movie on
Netflix she's like you don't buy me
flowers and I was like I bought you
flowers last week and she constantly
does that at me like she she lies about
the things I don't do for her she lies
why she Li she don't lie she just women
have short they have short memor when
was the last time you bought her flowers
for our anniversary when was your
anniversary
September September
27th my Dr [__] business four months
ago D you got to buy flowers at least
once a quarter of course you buy her a
couple flowers but then guess what you
buy in flowers and then it becomes not
so special anymore and then you do it
all the time you buy then you buy her
flower Trader Joe's doesn't sell just
one flower you I mean don't go to Trader
Joe's dude you go to the guy on the
freeway oh [__] give me just one one one
that and Mandarin oranges got you a back
I feel like dump it all over the bed
when you do set the mood when you do
though have a chance to go on a day and
then you [__] and you're just like man
this is sick why don't I do this often
like she's like right here it always
feels right and then you're like you got
[__] work as [__] I think that's what it
is cuz like it's also pre you got to do
chores around the house you got to clean
the house you don't want that sweaty
little [__] you want it to be ready for
you dude you want to be Daddy ready this
is this is not pristine yeah yeah
yeah I've been Ser I've been serving you
up garlic bread all night this is not a
pristine condition I don't want that I
don't need I don't need a hint of
oregano yeah we need Italian baby what
does garlic bread do to it nothing you
know it just come on it's just ask any
of your lady friends garlic bread ask
any of your lady friends before they
like make love after a date after they
eat some food sometimes they don't want
to make love after they had a big meal
hundo per you know what I mean oh yeah
yeah yeah you don't want to do all that
you got to go [__] light yeah few
pieces of Sashimi let me do the half
sandwi why aren't you feeding me on this
date why are we eating such small
appetiz cuz we're busting it down later
sweethe that's right the main course is
[__] getting dick down I brought
pillows and blankets in the car for us
that's funny to order for her with that
in mind oh no she'll only have a few
pieces of Simi cuz she's going to suck
my dick lady cuz the love making of
course we're going to [__] in the
car good Lord here's some complimentary
bread and butter no no no no no take it
back take it back we don't need that
I'll take some but she can't have it I
can house this stuff easy I need the
calories it is really true though that
every time you do have sex with your
girl you're like why are we not doing
this all the [__] time and then it
just doesn't come to mind sometimes he
just doesn't like I just don't think
about it the OTR it was how do you keep
the spark alive yeah how to keep the
spark alive we only talking about just
[__] we're talking about how
unbelievable it is that we get to [__]
any times what we want but we don't yeah
that's mostly what we talking about
that's true that's true cuz then I
remember like I can't wait till I grow
up I'mma have unlimited [__] you know
and then it's like you get unlimited
[__] and you're like why am I not how
come I'm not maximizing this but no we
maximize it but in ways we don't really
realize cuz in the morning sometimes I
just squeeze a booby and I'm like this
is awesome being that's true that's
yeah there's constant molestation con
that's the best part that's really fun I
know I just be in the elevator
going yeah and I'm credit carding the
butt I'm humping the but going up the
stairs is the best just like such a
violence you go first ladies first I
smack her butt all the way up the stairs
I've done it for years this is how you
know you've been together for a long
time when their butt defense is like
[__] it man like blindfolded it like
they butt defense yeah we go up and she
knows my combo so she's like
like right right [__] hamstring
[__] and I'm like what how how did
you know I was going to go like this
this this this this I'm trying to mix it
up that's a spear Wu
thing the [__] but it's with your ass
three hit three hit combo stupid no
eating on camera we've been together for
way way way too long see y Nick come on
Nick I love how that's our idea of spark
keeping the spark alive [__] feeling
up our women from time to time no we're
warming up the conversation we're
starting for the most driving and just
grabbing a titty out of nowhere we
touching a boob whenever we want that's
that's a it's no it it does add to the
convers like if she's like oh babe I got
to tell something like bad happened or
whatever he like tell me what I'm gred
okay tell me right now it changes the
don't do that to my tits Bro [__] okay
fine you can tell me but I have to be
like this oh by the way all you haters
out there who's say oh when I watch that
JK so male dominated you think we could
talk this openly if our [__] was here
there no there's no
chance like oh no like it's great I just
love her so
God you know it's a sick spark keeping
alive move is you just start just
dancing up on them for no reason you
just start while they're cooking while
they're cing or doing the
dishes yeah you just start shaking them
up it's night it's a fun time whenever
smack has like a really serious Zoom
yeah yeah those are the [__] I get up
on the bench and pull my pants down like
you hit him with one of
these you're just spitting on your head
yeah I do everything I try everything so
great and then like and then I got mad
at her because one time she's like I'm
sorry my boyf my boyfriend's just like
pulling his pants down and and I was
like don't tell them that's Levis
might be good Brandy I don't know this
recent thing happened that really
sparked up our spark see we're just warm
I like that I like that Vietnamese
language in the bedroom I used like it
but then Nick does like I
don't um basically so we were talking
about you know Christmas and Christmas
gifts and stuff and you know we were
getting gifts for everybody in our
family and so we finally looked at each
other we're like what what do you want
for Christmas what do you need to get me
and then you know we came to that
classic agreement in a long-term
relationship where it's like you don't
give me [__] I don't give you [__] yeah
let's just save money and do like
stocking stuffers like funny stocking
stuffers so we put up two stockings like
whatever you can put in the stocking
that's it right oh that's a good idea
kind cool yeah so in my mind I was like
I'm going to be awesome and I'm going to
lie to her I'm going to get her a little
like like funny just like prank stocking
stuffers and stuff but get still get her
a sick gift that's a [__] move Fu
dick that's that's a [__] very
selfish very selfish I just wanted to
win no wonder Nina said she had the
worst Christmas ever yep why where' she
say it she said in the girls private
chat the girl private chat she told that
to the girls in conference how do you
guys know how do you guys know she has a
block spot you don't know are you guys
in the chat she got a I was reading her
Tumblr the they tell us about it when
they tumblr's gone no when they have a
little bit of wine she said it on our
close friend
[Laughter]
story so um so so the beautiful thing is
that I get her a bunch of like really
little things for the stocking stuff
right but then her stocking stuffers
they all fit in the stocking but they're
like sick I'm talking like it's like a
new Rangefinder for my golfing it's like
it's like a piece of paper I'm like what
is this but it's like Broadway show
tickets you know what I mean like a show
that I wanted to see so it's like I'm
like sitting there and I'm like I got
her like this [__] thing that I saw
off Amazon like it's like I got her a
whoopy
cusher I got her like a cell phone
holder that she can clip to the bed post
so that she can watch her Tik Tok you
you got like novelty [__]
just really really small stuff but the
fact that she like went above and beyond
I was like [__] I thought I was being
like like funny and then I was going to
give her a real gift but now she's
whooping my ass so oofy doofy yeah you
know what I mean you were looking at it
before Christmas no not at all it's just
like on on Christmas when we were like
all it's time to share but the thing
that I was able to at least get she
really loves [__] handwritten cards
which I never doz some piece of [__] she
always writes me cards right you're son
of a [__] but this time this time I
wrote her a card and I got her a
different gift outside of the stocking
so it's like we I feel like we just kind
of at least match what's the outside of
the stocking gift she just wanted this
particular little purse thing dang my
bad basic
[__] I mean but um but you know just
the fact that like she went above and
beyond and then I also was like shady
and went Above and Beyond in a different
way at the same time that's cute that's
ciece of [__] and then she Rose to the
occasion yeah so it just it just we
looked at each other and we were just
like holy that is a Sparky spark yeah
that was better than us just getting
each other GI Christmas gifts like if it
was like what do you want for Christmas
I want this what do I want I want this
and we just get it it would have been
had no spark but you know we tried to
like con each other in a different way
actually she followed the rules in one
and then I was a con but it was very
when everybody wins we did the same
rules we said no gifts for Christmas and
we both did no gifts for Christmas [__]
it I did give her a water bottle though
I did go back on my word and get her
water it was a
Stanley you got the pink one huh I got a
purple one I got a purple one that ain't
the one no it's the one it's the one
that that survived the fire it's the one
you don't know [__] Ryan pink purple
purple yeah and I got a matching one for
myself I'm all about the aala what color
is yours purple yeah it's not rare oh I
got a gray one purple purple one but
aala you guys feel I got aala that's
cool man that's really cool we're big
water bottle family the purple one's
cool we're super in water
bottles sometimes you just need to grab
her
[__] I tried doing that I got yelled
at the other day yeah I got yelled at
sometimes I said hey can I sometimes if
I wanted to wake you up with sex and she
said absolutely not I said okay I'm so
sorry so very sorry that's a veteran
move I think yeah you wake up you're
later in the middle of night that's a
veteran question to ask oh yeah or are
you could do a first year marriage I I
don't think that's that's that crazy
first year is always okay what's first
year first year is just the it's [__]
the easiest year of all time dude first
year of marriage really Mar yeah bro cuz
riding a high though first year was hard
and then the second year was easy I
don't even know cut that because that
goes against his narrative yeah yeah
what the [__] cut you're three is the
hardest for sure cuz that goes against
the D no why why how come I think we got
a really crash course on like
relationship cuz like when we got
together we moved really quick so we had
the honeymoon like really quickly and
then we had the like crazy phase of just
like being married while having a new
place how while living in three places
and it was just crazy so we had to work
2023 2022 yeah 2022 so just yeah barely
one year and then so we were I think
there were layered things that we had to
solve
simultaneously while simultaneously
celebra things so it was just a it was
just a crazy cluster [__] where it was
like usually most people are like one
one thing at a time hey we got a house
all right let's marinate on that hey we
got married all right let's marinate on
that oh we had our first fight let's Mar
you
knowon dude it'll be
like 10 eventful things within a week
that makes sense and then so there was a
lot of that where we worked out really
quickly how to figure all these things
out and it was really awesome but then
since it was layered on top of each
other it was like what happened it was
it was pretty cool but now it's really
like Smooth Sailing and we just
understand each other much more how did
you push through like the the toughest
part there were a lot of tough Parts but
I think both of us the way that we both
are which made it like ultimately we
love each other a lot so we know that
there's no bad intentions it's just
miscommunication so when we chill out we
go what did you really mean by that cuz
we're really trying to each other and
then it diffuses the feeling of anger
and hate and then it we just get back to
a normal space but I think where we do
[__] up is like we're so in our heads
and in the zone that we don't celebrate
and take the time to be like hey we're
married let's enjoy this we're just like
we'll do spontaneous dates but not
planned so that's really fun right cuz
out of nowhere we're working our asses
off and then we're night swimming and
laughing and doing that [__] but then
when things happen like Christmas or
whatever it's like we're not getting
gifts you know we're missing birthdays
it's like so I think it's like it's just
a weird situation yeah sure well it's
circumstances though fits your life yeah
yeah you're a nomad dude yeah so there's
a I think there's a balance to
everything but it takes a nomad to get
with a nomad like you and her have that
energy together yeah I think that's
what's cool but then one of us has to be
a certain way or else we both never have
events that makes sense yeah that's cool
and we're just lost in the s
yeah yeah keep the spark High by just
grabbing her and [__] her I'm telling
you that's such good about at least you
guys are doing that though honestly
there's that's something that I'm sure
like out of all the dumb [__] we've said
more women are hearing that and going
that's what I'm saying just [__] me
already